the damage in the heart of grindavik
evidence of the swarm of earthquakes
that prompted its evacuation on Friday
and possibly a sign of worst to come a
sudden emission of toxic gas a possible
precursor to an eruption was enough for
authorities to order everyone out
Iceland's civil defense Chief clear that
the relative calm since Friday doesn't
mean the danger is gone the equipment
that we're using for measuring what's
going on is uh equipment that that
measures SO2 gases which is a volcanic
gases
would indicate that lava is very close
to the surface so we had a warning from
that system so we evacuated people
working in the in the area residents
who'd been allowed back in to collect
important possessions caught up in this
second
evacuation inun had to rely on a friend
to get her things she was away from home
on Friday night and now doesn't know
when or if she'll be allowed back for me
I'm completely num to this I just
haven't processed the feeling right now
so it's really really uh hard for me to
understand what's going on what's
happening what's about to happen and
what's the future what the future
holds Iceland's Southwest Peninsula has
always been a literal hot spot of
volcanic activity it sits on the join
where two tectonic plates pull apart
even so there's been nothing on the
scale of this emergency since
interruption in the 13th century but the
fear for this peninsula and the people
who live here is that this isn't just
about an imminent eruption it's about a
long-term shift into a much more
volcanically active and dangerous phase
ra Peterson has been monitoring
Iceland's volatile geology for more than
20 years she says what's happened in the
last few days is evidence of a
transition that could last centuries the
last eruption was in
1240 um but now this is quite an usual
pattern what's seen is that the
peninsula will be dormant until a new
active period starts and that can also
last several hundreds of years fears of
an explosive eruption at Sea are now
diminishing but a devastating flow of
lava could still destroy grindavik
Iceland's Beauty has been forged in part
by its 32 active volcanic systems its
people have had to become resilient to
their dangers but here in the southwest
those dangers are only growing Harry
forcet Al jazer Southern
Iceland make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer